de lo que quiero hablar en este vídeo es
sobre el litro ok quiero hablar sobre el
litro y el litro es una unidad para
medir el volumen de líquidos es decir
cuánto espacio ocupa algún líquido o
algún fluido así que como se ve un litro
bueno una de estas botellas déjenme las
marco cada una de estas botellas de
leche es de un litro dentro de cada
botella hay un litro de leche y
típicamente uno piensa en litros en la
vida diaria cuando compramos bebidas
verdad el detalle es que cuando vamos a
comprar leche o vamos a comprar agua a
veces encontramos envases que no son de
un litro pueden ser de dos litros o
quizás de tres litros o quizás algunas
otras medidas pero esta botella de leche
es de
un litro muy bien y por supuesto
escribimos l para describir digamos de
forma breve que es un litro ok a veces
también se pueden usar mayúsculas
digamos l mayúscula pero vamos a dejar
solo l minúscula muy bien entonces esa
es la forma de representar los litros y
en este digamos en esta imagen hay seis
litros verdad cada botella es de un
litro de leche así que tenemos seis
litros en total ahora qué pasaría si
tenemos volúmenes más pequeños por
ejemplo lo que puede estar contenido en
un gotero verdad en este caso
en este caso tendremos que usar no los
litros si no los mililitros y que están
muy relacionados entonces tenemos mil
litros que mililitros el prefijo mili
quiere decir que es una milésima parte
entonces un mililitro quiere decir que
es una milésima parte es uno entre mil
de un litro ok
u otra forma de decirlo es que
necesitamos mil mililitros para hacer un
litro ok entonces decíamos que los
mililitros son digamos formas de medir
el volumen de líquidos cuando tenemos
una cantidad muy pequeña de líquidos
verdad entonces en este caso denotamos a
los mililitros como m l muy bien m para
1000 y l para litros muy bien entonces
aquí tenemos el ejemplo de un gotero
puede ser un gotero para para medicinas
o algo así y este gotero tiene una
digamos tiene algunas marcas que van
indicando un mililitro dos mililitros
tres mililitros y así quizás hasta cinco
mililitros digamos que lo que tenemos
dentro de este gotero es un mililitro
puede ser de medicina o de cualquier
otro líquido ahora bien también
podríamos pensar por ejemplo en una
cuchara digamos una cucharada de líquido
más o menos es cinco mililitros verdad
entonces lo que estamos diciendo con
esto es que necesitaríamos mil veces lo
que hay en este gotero para llenar toda
esta botella de leche de un litro o bien
necesitaríamos 200 cucharadas de leche
para llenar la botella verdad y
necesitamos 200 porque cada cada
cucharada tiene 5 mililitros entonces si
tenemos 200 por 5 tenemos mil mililitros
qué es
un litro verdad entonces tenemos que un
litro es igual a mil mililitros ok
un litro es igual a mil mililitros ahora
qué pasaría si tenemos cosas mucho más
grandes que la escala digamos de una
botella de leche por ejemplo aquí
tenemos que la botella de leche es de un
litro pero del lado derecho tenemos una
alberca verdad ésta puede ser no sé una
una alberca una alberca olímpica que son
muy largas verdad que de hecho son de 50
metros de largo entonces si uno hace la
cuenta y espero estés preparado para
este resultado si uno hace las cuentas
podemos ver que en una alberca olímpica
de digamos 50 metros de largo por 25 de
ancho y 2 metros de profundidad
tenemos estás listo tenemos 2 millones y
medio
litros es un montón verdad son
muchísimos muchísimos litros y tú dirás
bueno a lo mejor son muy raras las
albercas olímpicas qué pasaría si mi
mejor amigo tiene una alberca en su casa
oa lo mejor tú mismo tienes una alberca
en tu casa por supuesto esas no son tan
grandes pero de todas formas una alberca
más o menos digamos que uno podría tener
una casa tiene más de cien mil litros
100 mililitros es una cosa impresionante
de de agua verdad
entonces nuevamente para para resumir
todo esto si estamos pensando en
cucharadas o en goteros estamos en el
rango de los mililitros si pensamos en
cosas que puedes beber en un día o que
tu familia puede beber en una semana
entonces estamos en el rango de litros
ahora bien si piensas en la cantidad de
líquido que se necesita para llenar una
alberca estamos en el rango de miles o
quizás hasta millones de litros